[Music]
well of course Los Angeles is the word
show capital of the world we got the
Oscars the Emmys the Golden Globes but
none of these award shows pay tribute to
the most important group of people
that's the studio audience I'm gonna
rectify that right now by honoring our
audience in tonight's Conan audience e
Awards and finally our last award will
go to one lucky audience member chosen
at random they're not just getting a
trophy they're getting a new car isn't
this exciting audience really excited
but here's a catch you only get to keep
the car if you can drive it out of our
studio in under 30 seconds right now
live on the show here we go the winner
is the person in seat 90 here she goes
here she goes
[Music]
[Music]
that's the winner
waiting for the funny part some things
aren't funny it's just a good news for
her she's got a car doesn't she doesn't
something happen that's funny
no what I thought we wrote jokes here
she won a car can't you just feel good
for another human she faked one a fake
car what's up well he should have gotten
here me he almost got hit he got safely
out of the way that's comedy Maria when
people safely avoid a problem that's
every Pink Panther movie Clouseau almost
caused the problem
but sidestepped it oh I'd rather be this
guy Oh Conan right now
you
you